celle là tous depuis deux semaines une
polémique oppose charlie hebdo à
mediapart
suite à des révélations sur la vie de
tariq ramadan de loin on peut voir les
choses de façon laïque républicain
contre islamo-gauchiste aurait acquis
ces robes entre défenseurs de la
tolérance
et bien voici quelques éléments
clairement nos objectifs pour tenter de
comprendre la situation
edwy plenel est un ancien trotskiste qui
milité à la lcr dans les années soixante
dix il était même journaliste salarié
par le journal de l'organisation rouge
chez lui journalisme et militantisme
toujours été mélangés même quand il a
pris la direction du monde
un livre retrace d'ailleurs ces années
d'instrumentalisation et à mon avis
l'adn les sens politique d'edwy plenel
jusqu'à aujourd'hui peut être résumée
par l'un de ses articles écrit en 1972
dans rouge en septembre 1972 lors des
jeux olympiques de munich
un groupe palestinien a fait septembre
noir prend des sportifs israéliens en
otages et la faire tourner au carnage 11
otages sont exécutés par les ravisseurs
la lcr des fins terroristes et c'est
plenel sous le pseudonyme de joseph
krasznai qui se charge de porter la
parole de l'organisation
voici ce qu'il écrit aucun
révolutionnaire ne peut se désolidariser
de septembre noir
nous devons défendre
inconditionnellement face à la
répression les militants de cette
organisation
oui en 1972 par tiers mondisme plein
elle va justifier l'assassinât de civils
que défendre l'organisation qui en est à
l'origine
la dédouanant au passage moralement du
carnage et aujourd'hui encore cédé
radicaliser en apparence edwy plenel est
toujours compréhensibles par ce prisme
du tiers-mondisme les peuples pauvres
sont opprimés dans toutes les dimensions
de la vie économique mais aussi
politique puisque les pays riches les
contrôles seraient toujours en sous main
et quand ils sont dans des pays
occidentaux qui sont en plus opprimés
religieusement ce sont des nouveaux
martyrs des victimes ab-so-lu-ment
l'occident capitaliste et générateur de
tous les malheurs du monde y compris
indirectement de l'islamisme qui serait
une réaction à ces injustices haut doubs
l'ardeur de plenel à défendre liste d'un
bec et ongles quoi qu'il arrive ou
encore l'habitude de crier au racisme
d'état
dès qu'un petit délinquant les rougets
chat et de la souris et si en ce moment
on a droit à des invectives
il ya des arguments souvent de mauvaise
foi entre charlie hebdo et mediapart
c'est parce qu'il est difficile voire
impossible à gauche de débattre de la
place de l'islam en france notamment à
cause de la gauche mediapart et son
intransigeance
car pour plenel et les siens ouvrir le
débat sur la place de l'islam en france
c'est déjà être islamophobe et donc être
l'ennemi par exemple frais récemment et
jules un vidéaste employés par mediapart
bien connu des jeunes générations à
assimiler gauche laïque islamophobe et
islamophobie à racisme expliquant en
plus sont ensuite que le fascisme c'est
un gradient pratique et pas seulement
une idéologie insinuant donc que la
gauche laïque s'est déjà l'antichambre
du fascisme
ces altercations par médias interposés
sont donc le seul moyen très navrant
pour la gauche d'affirmer très
indirectement les différentes positions
sur l'islam en france les tensions qui
traversent à gauche sur la question de
l'islam ne trouvant comment s'exprimer
finisse comme toute tension tous
trouvent pas moyen de s'exprimer par le
débat et les échanges en violences et vu
la rigidité idéologique de plenel
les violences interethniques à gauche
entre laïcs et islamo gauchistes ne sont
pas près de s'éteindre
et ce n'est pas l'intervention des
casques bleus du monde qui va changer
les choses
l'invectivé et la polémique risque de
rester les seuls moyens d'échanger sur
ce sujet encore longtemps
j'espère que cette petite vidéo fait un
petit peu à larache clairement pas
médiapart rendez vous aura tout de même
apporté des billes pour comprendre le
clash entre charlie hebdo à mediapart y
aller tous